what do you think about alpha fold too i
don't know if you've been paying
attention to that
well the them uh deep mind solving the
protein folding problem
and then also releasing
first of all
open sourcing the code which is for me
as a software person that i love and
then second of all also making
like 300 000 predictions or something
like that for different protein
structures and releasing that data
yeah so on the side of because you make
you're saying there's dark matter right
is there something
um what first what are your general
thoughts level of excitement about their
uh their work and second how can that be
applied to
viruses do you think we'll be able to
explore the dark matter of
virology using machine learning
absolutely because in all this dark
sequence you can
translate it and make a protein you can
see what a protein looks like it has
what we call an open reading frame right
a start and a stop and right now it's
just a bunch of amino acids but if we
could
fold it maybe the fold would recognize
like something we already know some
protein fold which gives you a lot of
clues right because there are only so
many protein folds
in biology and that dark matter is
probably one of them
so i think that's very exciting because
for years i followed structural
biologists
for years and
you know in the beginning we couldn't
even solve structures of viruses they're
too big we could do small molecules like
myoglobin that was the first one done
took years to do that and then
as computational power increase then
they could start to do viruses but it
took a long time
x-ray crystallography
depended on getting crystals of the
virus right and now we can do
cryo-electron microscopy which is much
faster
you could solve the spike of stars cov2
was solved in two months by by jason
mcclelland here in austin actually at
the beginning of the pandemic
but you're limited you can't do
huge proteins you can only do moderately
sized ones
so or i should actually you can do
viruses but you can't do small proteins
so that's speeded it up but it's still
too fast to solve you get a new protein
you want to solve its structure so if we
could predict it and i know from talking
to structural biologists this has been
their holy grail from day one they want
to be able to take a sequence of a
protein put it in a computer and have
the structure put out without having to
do all the experiment so that's why this
is very exciting that yeah you can
predict it i mean it's not
finished obviously and there's more to
do but i think it will be a day where
you could take any amino acid sequence
and predict what it's going to look like
see but like aren't structural
biologists going to get greedy so once
you have that don't you want to go more
complicated then don't you want to go
because that's that's just the first
step right to go from amino acid to the
structure then there's like multiple
protein interactions like how do you get
to the virus
well so that's what the ultimate goal of
getting a structure is that then you can
do experiments and figure out what the
structure means right so many
in the old days structural biology was a
career in itself you worked with people
who had a system and you solved proteins
for them and then you moved on to
another one you didn't really do any
experiments the other people got to do
all the interesting experiments right
now
young structural biologists are
multifaceted they solve the structure
and then they say what happens if we
change this amino acid oh look it it
blocks binding to the receptor this must
be the receptor binding interface so
that's the exciting stuff absolutely is
doing the experiment
you